[Music]
the Stars season announcements I mean
people are going crazy over the lineup
who do you think is going to really
bring it this season who are you you
know what's so interesting not being a
part of the show anymore so it's
essentially looking at it from an
outside perspective but I certainly love
Lindsey Stirling I think she's the most
amazing down-to-earth girl in the world
so I'm really rooting for her and Jordan
Fischer's fantastic and but will you
never know you know you never know until
you see him for the first time
Julianne she just she just got married
she looked like she's glowing how how is
she how is she adjusting to being a wife
and and how do you like in your brother
lost I love him
I have me I love him so much he's
amazing man and she's they're adjusting
to it fantastically like I mean I mean
adjusting like you know people say like
you know his life changed when you're
married in their case it has and the
absolute better so yeah I mean we got to
talk about world of dance I mean you
guys are a phenomenal cast you know well
next season is gonna be you know we're
gonna have to double the hours to be
like 26 hours of episodes so it's
fantastic and amazing and bigger and
better than ever you know that our first
season and we might have some
performances ourselves you know me the
judges we might get out there and dance
and you know yeah oh yeah we're gonna
step it up a notch definitely so we're
excited about it
[Music]
you